on va jouer à michèle laroque ou l'autre
michel bourgeois michel ou l'autre
michel a failli tourner avec leonardo
dicaprio michel maman dans arrête-moi si
tu peux et leo dicaprio web ou catch me
if you can jouer la maman de narducci le
président que j'ai failli c'est que je
voulais et spielberg a dit mais
n'importe quoi tu es trop jeune serbie
pour tous et non mais c'est plutôt
agréable
tu vois quand on te dit je suis assez
d'accord avec lui et après je l'avais
rencontré à cannes dicaprio et à une
soirée puis on me dit on lui dit ah ben
justement michel maille made est alors
chaque fois que je les rencontre et ce
soir là le public il y en avait vraiment
ras-le-bol je disais je peux être à même
ces noms font appel explique ben may va
appeler pour les dents de la mer ont
joué quoi l'euro comme trop basanée
millions d'euros ne fait pas bon on n'y
croit pas stark un tunisien
nathalie baye qui avait eu bien sûr
exactement c'est l'humain michel ou
l'autre michel la fillette kidnappée
dans sa jeunesse michel michel la
rentrée michel est serré bref tout nappé
quand même la roumanie ouais je sais pas
ce que sous ma mère donc s'était échappé
il n'avait pas apprécié parce que ça
avait pas fait de la pub au régime et je
suis allé à l'âge de 7 ans rencontré mon
grand père qui était malade et qu'il
voulait me connaître j'étais avec mon
père ma mère condamnée la balle j'aurais
pu mettre les pieds et jaune n'a dormi
chez des amis de la famille bon et tout
d'un coup en pleine nuit j'ai le
cauchemar total à sept ans en plus un
type est arrivée par le toit par la
fenêtre esterra tu vois il
j'ai hurlé tout le monde est arrivé bon
ils sont repartis et c'est essai à
cesser les méthodes non mais c'est les
méthodes c'était pour me garder en otage
pour cela revenir ma mère qui aurait
dire oui je regrette mon pays
merveilleux que je manque c'est
traumatisant comme mais attends je sais
mais c'est même là que le cauchemar
aussi si les gars là tu vois je
m'inquiète pas c'est que ce talent
ivoirien michel ou l'autre michel a été
papa radier bon d'être célèbre jeu le
pitch elle c'est michel drucker va
devoir en semaine prochaine ou celle
d'après midi la paroisse michel qui nous
regardent souvent et qu'on aime il avait
16 17 ans il était photographe de plage
et signe à prendre des photos de couples
un fidèle pour ensuite le revendre les
photos mais celle des acteurs roumains
il émane en oxygène c'est vraiment qu'on
embrasse michel qui vient de voir très
vite là mais celle où l'autre michel va
chanter en duo avec didier bourdon
oui c'est donc sur l'album de didier
bourdon qui va bientôt sortir
oui c'est vrai tu vas et est serré que
tu es tu chantes aussi dans le film
chacun chez soi une chanson de gaëtan
roussel michel ou l'autre michel a
couché avec johnny hallyday selon
certaines rumeurs
notre mission à l'autre michel c'est
michel sardou away
et ouais alors il doit raconter
l'histoire en fait michel sardou et
johnny se rendait à un concert des
restos du coeur
ils font le trajet en moto tous les deux
ils arrivent fatigués comme à l'hôtel
voilà ils vont tous les deux à l'hôtel
prennent une chambre et d'hommes
ensemble et le patron de l'hôtel a
commencé à dire à tout le monde que
sardou et johnny était en somme c'est de
faire coller cette histoire oui oui
absolument
elle faisait la tournée à l'époque avec
véronique sanson oui avec johnny n'a pas
nui à ma première année avec jean
jacques goldman et en fait c'est vrai
que du coup comme il n'y avait pas de
moyens non plus la journée ouais non
mais ils ont dormi ensemble c'est tous
ensemble
si la rumeur l'a été tanase lors des
rencontres le mec qui amène le petit déj
le matin qui tombe sur michel sardou
[Rires]
garder quand on était en tournée tout
les [ __ ] on s'était arrêté dans une
station service pour acheter des trucs
bon ça fait quand même 40 mec donc la
guerre elle était comme ça évidemment je
crois que c'est francis cabrel d'aller
aux toilettes il a entendu deux routiers
parler en effet à je sais c'est la
tournée des sosies
[Rires]
c'est très bon michel ou l'autre michel
aurait voulu faire danse avec les stars
avec muriel robin et d'autres stars non
non c'est michel muriel a eu cette idée
ait animé sur les gros ça super cool way
est pas select'om que nous deux on a
arrêté à l'avenir va peut-être venir
michel ou l'autre michel et visiter 2,5
millions de fois par an c'est le bon
sens la classe fortis est pas là pour
savoir